this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by omax cryofreeze
and hello fresh more on that later let's
get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it at the night pants studios i am
ryan sickler
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com make sure you're subscribed
to the
the email newsletter make sure you are
subscribed to the youtube channel you're
gonna get video there every tuesday
uh patreon show the honeydew with y'all
uh you guys have some crazy stuff we
have heard a lot of crazy [ __ ] out there
and i never get enough of it so
if you or someone you know has a story
you absolutely think needs to be heard
please email us at honeydewpodcast
gmail.com uh facebook fan page
all that stuff the honeydewpodcast.com
is the website that's where you get the
merch
again and again and again thank you
night pants nation and thank you night
shorts nation you guys are [ __ ]
killing it i love it send a pic so i can
promote them
you know what's up there hoodies mugs
all that stuff
uh and santa monica music center if you
are looking for online musical lessons
this is the
spot go to santa monica music dot com
use my code honeydew they will waive the
registration fee and you'll get one free
lesson
when you sign up for a package all right
that's the honeydewpodcast.com for
everything honeydew related
it's ryan sickler.com for everything
ryan sickler related
now that that is all out of the way you
know we do over here we highlight the
low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and uh today's guest is
special for me this is a
a great friend of mine and we'll get
into what else is going on with this
episode but
uh ladies and gentlemen please welcome
for the first time here on the honeydew
gary adler everybody welcome to the
honeydew gary thank you ryan thank you
other vikings all right that's fine
let me straighten this out uh yeah so um
well first of all uh please
go ahead and plug anything no you know
what no let's do a little differently
this time
gary and i are old friends we go back to
god
98 9 somewhere in there
started in comedy together um at a spot
called the boat house which
unfortunately now is
bubba gump shrimp shrimp on the [ __ ]
pier but it was a once a month show
first friday
something like that something like that
saturday mm-hmm
uh but you couldn't get 20 minutes of
set anywhere back then
and and so many great comedians came
through there from cat williams chris
hardwick
uh there was a lot of people rolled
through there earthquake
earthquake alonzo bowden yup um
yeah come up on this mic just pull it
toward you tons of great comedians came
down there
and um yeah that's when you and i just
kind of really got to know each other
really well and you um were wise and
stopped comedy
not because you weren't funny but
because it's [ __ ] it's for [ __ ]
it wasn't that it really wasn't it was
the right move
well it probably was for me at the time
i you know what it is
is um i don't have like an accent or
speak weird or
look strange or do i and you know you
kind of need that
delivery you know like if you look at
the great comics like chris
rock and and um and even louis ck and
whoever else is out there the good ones
seem to have
like this weird affectation and that you
get
it's like a hook and i could i could
write a craft a good joke
tell a good joke but um i just never had
that hook you know
and so i felt like i'd be better off as
a writer
and that's what i just started doing and
writing and designing and stuff like
that um
and i just had said to you know look i
got this new space and i really want to
do
something like old-school 70s stuff i
sent you a few samples and
of course you do what you do right away
and see it in a different world you
start sending me all this [ __ ] back so
a lot of people ask like what the [ __ ]
behind you i have yet to say anything
because i wanted to do this so
this logo which yeah somebody it is a
little crooked it's a little tilted but
you know what it wouldn't be the
[ __ ] honeydew studio if it
wasn't broken
it is it's way crooked first of all and
i was so convinced
i was back here like i don't know i
gotta go get my you're like ryan
i was like i got that [ __ ] ryan i got
that one try
and by the way it goes up with the
sloping [ __ ]
i overestimated my abilities to execute
on the design a lot and i think
you had to go over a few things like i
painted these stripes and boy were they
a mess and then
you had a guy come in and do a really
nice you found that guy
oh that's right there you go and by the
way back there you never get to see it
but there's ryan's [ __ ] a giant
honeydew
just off screen here yeah point to it
that's it
yeah just like american pie he's just
banging a giant [ __ ] rotten honey
what is behind me is a collage of
honeydew pictures that you put together
i sent you a bunch of [ __ ] and
from your instagram these are stuff you
people have sent
or tagged or whatever i don't know some
of them might be yours
but my favorite one so everybody wants
to know why the new side ryan why
i'll tell you why there was a thinking
behind it it wasn't just
something i thought and this is the
truth it's a new studio i thought i'd
try new things i'll sit on a new side of
the table
and also not i want to i want to i don't
care about anything anymore this virus
hasn't given up
[ __ ] man i don't care i don't care
about anything anymore the hair
none of it i don't give a [ __ ] i care
when it should start i don't give a [ __ ]
anymore
so i thought new side [ __ ] new studio
do everything different emphasize your
weaknesses
not that i have a good side but this one
ain't it okay
so i purposely sat on this side with the
gap on my teeth because i don't give a
[ __ ] anymore i am celebrating all of my
weaknesses
and my insecurities because i don't give
a [ __ ] anymore but this picture right
here
are you gonna get to show that to people
eventually we can maybe take a photo and
put it on there for sure yeah
we can do that but um
this one some one of you out there
at a restaurant or a job or something
got a pov
shot of this dude here passing up this
perfectly good honeydew
for some cannabis
that's some sleuthing right there just
sit in front of that too because that is
perfect you just passed right on so
yeah i mean this you came to you said
look i'm i'm kind of holed up with my ex
and my and my my stepson and my daughter
yeah we're all quarantined
and you said i need a masturbation
castle so please
if you don't mind just just help me make
this thing yeah and this was the picture
from nebraska that you put the honeydew
on we have a
that's right we'll take some photos and
include it in this the highlight and the
lowlights above the wall here yeah
there's a bunch of cool [ __ ] y'all
aren't seeing so hit him up
it's nice it's and uh it's really well
done
uh so thank you because this was a lot
of [ __ ] work
and then you know after we had to reset
it up after the riots but here we are
i tell you and i'm here i wish i would
have jumped in my car and came down here
but i did call
and you go dude the lights are on it's
probably over and uh and at that point i
was like
what am i gonna do
i wish i could have done something so
look i i
can't thank you enough for all your help
all the fans have
it's been very positive there's a couple
people like what a weird color pattern
but
that's on me i picked the colors so you
did i threw in white so we could put
some more accents
it was your logo and everything that's
this is jeff teice to design this logo
and the artwork
we got annie and ash working here ethan
i think it's wolferman i hope i just
said that can i just mix those two up by
the way
yep oh you did you called him manny i
didn't that's their way to go
way to go out to take you to hr after oh
my god
so now that that's all out of the way
people been wondering i've been having
i've been i've saved it for this episode
so there it is that's what's
who you are that's what's going on
that's how this all came about we
it was nice though because this is like
you know when my daughter's older this
is my
uh what i built during the depression
you know what i mean this is my
coronavirus
we had the riots we had everything
that's where dad started a meat packing
plant right there
man i'm telling you and for me just so
you know
it gave me something to do like on the
weekends um
but uh there was a guy here and it was
all weird for a little bit but then
everybody kind of cleared out yeah once
they yeah once they couldn't afford here
anymore that was the when
lana was like look these guys are
leaving and i was like well i'm gonna
come in then
yeah yeah she seems really awesome i saw
her on that episode and um
yeah i wish i it feels like i i should
know her but i just don't you know we'll
introduce you there you go so we also
have uh
i want to help you um i want to show
everybody what you got here you have a
comic book out right that's right right
yeah and here's let's talk
a little backstory everything um yeah
this is where a good place i could
tell you where to go to to find the
comic book and all that stuff but um
first of all uh it was you who came to
me
and said you were coming off a couple
comedy central shows
um that were good i thought were great
actually and um
and you said hey man i'm um i want to go
back out with some stuff what do you
have i know you used to pitch things
so i think i sent you like six or seven
days a lot of good stuff
and you said hey what about this thing
and
um i said that that was the last one i
did no one's ever seen it you know i
just got
kind of tired of the industry and kind
of tired of pitching i used to pitch
animated shows you know that was my deal
yeah i just get anxiety thinking about
brushing it yeah
but but you and i we we put a deck
together we went out and pitched and we
you know we got a little traction with
it seems like some
some people really dug the concept but
then we got into that old rut
of you know hey go back and do notes and
blah blah blah and
at this point in my career just like you
said in your life just like you said
[ __ ] [ __ ] it man i'm not doing it so you
know what i'm going to do i'm just going
to make it myself and that's what i did
i got one for you
the finger off look at this yeah dude
there it is can you see that put that
right here
yeah commando place and you know it's
good because look
on the second page there's a small
person with a giant dildo
and she's getting ready to bang a sumo
warrior who's doing cocaine
so it can only get better from here
folks
wow this is really well done though it
really is man thank you and i got to
thank
my artists um shin mamochu
who um his actual name is is mamochu but
his
his real name is carl contreras thank
you dude yeah that's for you and there's
a dedication in there for you
thank you but uh my artist is an
interesting story he um it's like the
he he's an amazing artist but he what he
does for commissions is he
draws really sexy stuff for commission
yeah yeah and um so it's kind of a
pretty woman situation where i really
want this thing to be super successful
and and get him out of that you know
business a little bit
right and get into the mainstream
because i know that
um i want to make five more of these
comic books there's five more to go and
then i got another series i want to do
after it
and i really want to employ him the
whole time so um
i got a kickstarter campaign going so if
you guys go to kickstarter
and look up my name gary adler or
commando place you'll go right to the
kickstarter page g-a-r-y-a-d-l-e-r
gary
could you imagine it went like that
that'd be great design
it's funny you you know you and i have
been in the promo business for so long
you know and um
and promoting your own thing is a very
your own brand
yeah is it you know can be can be
complicated and difficult
and tough to make decisions you know
really hard to make decisions
so um you know i'm really proud that i
was able to do this
um book and uh i'm hoping people can
help me make
five more of them so uh go to uh
commando place
um on instagram you'll see a lot of the
cool frames from that from the book
and um go to amazon the books available
on amazon.com
in book format and in digital format if
you only want to spend like three bucks
oh no so yeah help me out guys i
appreciate
all your support and your fans are super
awesome so they're the best
yeah they're the best and if they're
comic book fans i know they'll go get
this
um so let's start talking about it and
we got all that out of the way
a million times thank you for all your
help on this you don't have to thank me
at all
family and everything no it was nice
well i got two uh grown-up boys you know
and uh
great kids they're great kids but um out
of the house they're great to other
people
you know yeah but you know how it is too
i mean i can't imagine what is it 19 and
17
20 and 17 but i gotta say though after
about three weeks
and my boys notoriously do not get along
you know they're completely opposite
kids
um but after about three or four weeks
everyone was so tired
you know [ __ ] yeah who cares
[ __ ] i'll be in my room wanna tell me
what dinner is so tell me what it was
like for you
getting older growing up like they have
such a different life than you did
yeah i mean it was about this time i
think my dad
kind of just stopped talking
you know like about this time in his
life yeah where he was just like [ __ ] it
i've said enough
and if people need to talk to me they'll
come there is a real art
to not giving a [ __ ] anymore there's an
art to like absolutely there is
but he was you know he was good like if
i ever had an issue with him or needed
to ask a question or something about the
family
always always had a lot of information
he just wasn't forthcoming with it like
hey did you know blah blah blah it just
wasn't that guy
that's silent yeah that's my brother
he's like that
like hey man how you guys doing
everybody good yeah
that's it but then that's it yeah i'm
like but you could draw it out of him
bro
i can you have to but and he will like
well how are the kids doing uh yeah
tate's doing all right little league
that's it
no one assisted triple plays nothing no
highlights no what's the record
you know none of that nothing
yeah he's doing good at short stops
maddie's in uh she's in a a
recital i've never met your brother dude
you guys seem super opposite yeah we are
and then he goes uh he has almost cried
and i said you know what next time let
yourself you know my god
push them out oh man
yeah my kids don't get on but i'm super
happy because in december
uh our family threw a huge surprise
party for my dad who's
90 oh wow and my stepmom who's 70 and
they've been together
for 40 years you know and um
um start you can do the math it's 50 and
third
so uh thank goodness we did that
with all the family and friends in this
one
venue and great celebration
and uh we had the the band that was
played their wedding came back and
played for them and they're all still
alive
everyone's still on crazy right but um
because we couldn't do it now like i
can't even i don't even know when i'm
gonna see my dad next you know like he
lives in miami in a condo like what
am i flying there yeah it's just weird
right now so um
i'm just super thankful that the family
could get together that that time in
december you know that was cool so what
was
where your parents got divorced though
right yeah my parents when i was 11.
my parents got divorced and uh
immediately i don't think it affected me
that much
um affected my older brother a lot why
i think he's just older and it kind of
hit him hit him a little harder
like the the reality of separation and
and and uh you know the uncertainty of
it all
you're all in florida at the time we
were and then my my mom met a guy and we
moved to
colorado so now why does mom get to take
the kids
or was dad cool with it you know i doubt
he was cool with it
i really do um and in fact i'm sure he
wasn't cool with it but
i don't think there was much he could do
about it at the time you know just based
on the laws back then yeah
back then plus it's florida they
probably yeah so we moved to colorado
with this
guy that my mom was dating um his son
became a very famous actor
and um he and i palled around a little
bit together in colorado he
he was this huge dude at 15 he was like
six four 250 big big fellas damn he was
that big then
yeah he was huge [ __ ] and um uh
i was just a little [ __ ] you know and uh
11 years old 12 years old and he was a
magician at the time i was his
magician's assistant you know
and you know what i'm talking about i
don't know if i could say it or not um
but it was
it's uh vincent d'onofrio you know who
that is yeah so yeah
his dad and my mom hooked up in the
theater in miami
he was a director and then we all moved
to colorado
and uh they were step brothers for a
minute yeah we were sort of step
brothers
yeah but we got in a lot of trouble
together like um there was one time when
uh we were walking
we lived on rainbow hill road if
anyone's from colorado they know this
street is very famous it out looks over
el rancho restaurant
and we were walking down the street wait
is el rancho the restaurant that
south park does what the guys are cliff
diving and did it it's like all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] in colorado
or like they're diving off the thing and
they got the bands everywhere
it's probably rancho restaurants on off
of the i-70 and our backyard looked
right at the el rancho restaurant
i don't remember there being cliff
diving or anything
somebody out there don't know what that
restaurant is you know
south park is a cartoon [ __ ]
restaurant
so anyway uh yeah walk down the street
commando place
oh there's absolutely no
um we're walking down the street and we
see over the side of the
cliff we see this garbage bag right
flies and stuff
like ah let's go see what's in that
garbage bag so we go in there
how old are you i'm probably 12. and
you're always probably 16. yeah it's
just the two of us
and uh so we go down and we see it's a
german shepherd
it's dead it's in the garbage bag so we
go home and call the cops
and then we go back and hide up in the
woods and wait
and just watch the whole scene go down
what do you tell em's in the bag
we said we don't know what's in the bag
we're not sure we saw flies and blah
blah blah and then
it was back then where you didn't have
to wait for the cops you know
we just perched ourselves above the the
tree line and
was watched and watched him sweat it out
hard
hardcore man and the dude came down
there and he was like
it's just a dog it's just a dog the next
guy took the dog you know and we were
like okay
oh man we had a lot of fun we
[Laughter]
he's a good guy you know i never really
followed up with him after
um we moved back to miami i was gonna
say you've never reached out or anything
i i wrote a screenplay once with him in
mind as the villain
and i reached out to his agent he'd look
great on this he would be awesome yeah
straighten the commando plays vincent
d'onofrio you could do a vo for that
vincent dennis
come on man um so then we moved back to
miami and uh
then we were apartment kids for a while
yeah that was interesting that was cool
you had never been is that the first
time you've been in an apartment meeting
i remember going from a house to an
apartment like
what's this we don't have a yard we
don't have any place to go we gotta
like outside as soon as you step outside
you're off your property
yeah you know and that was new to me and
we were
we were just [ __ ] nuts in there too
because it was just my mom she had no
control over us we were doing drugs and
[ __ ] around and skateboarding yeah oh
my god what age did you start
uh i started smoking weed in colorado
when i was 14.
damn okay and in colorado we had
we had jocks we had hippies and we had
cowboys
which was a new thing for me coming from
miami i was like this hippie kid with
long hair
and i remember the first day of school
at bergen elementary school
it was it was like three feet of snow
outside and they're like all right
recess
and i like i'm from miami all right
we're gonna draw
you know i can do some blocks and we
went outside and played football in the
snow and i just got my ass kicked dude i
was like god damn
these kids are hardcore man and uh then
the [ __ ] cowboys
who literally had giant cowboy belts on
and they rode in rodeos and all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] that was a whole nother
factor
that i just it was this out of my
element yeah you know but that's when i
started smoking
weed and getting in with the the jocks
and hippies you know
seemed to be the same crowd sometimes
and then you went back to florida
and what at what age were you there 17
13 14.
and then what that's high school years
there yeah i started wrestling junior
high school i know you're a wrestler too
yeah i love wrestling yeah me too i
think it taught me a lot
about life i was good and i got a funny
story when i was in
my senior year of high school wrestling
i didn't cut any weight for the first
time in my life i've never had i i
never did that i was never able to just
not cut weight yet yeah i was just
i always wrestled the smallest weight
class but and
and when i was a senior i wrestled 122
right that was my natural weight wow
yeah
so uh which is like so light you know
but um
but um so we we changed districts to
district 15
from district 16 and there was a couple
good teams in there
and at district finals our entire team
made the finals damn every weight class
every single weight class
and i remember almost getting stuck
looking up at the lights
and looking over at my coach and he's
like dude you don't want to be the one
yeah oh i reversed it
you know did the bridge stuck him and i
was like yeah i'm in
but at night you know when the finals
came around the lights went out
you know the light comes down yeah the
light comes down and our whole team
was on one side of the mat and all the
other teams were on the other side
and that was the front page of the paper
the next day so that was kind of a cool
moment
you know sports moment for me and i lost
my my match pretty good but they do
that's all right i got it wiped up a lot
a lot
not a lot but whenever i gave up weight
to a guy who had
muscle if i was giving up 10 pounds to a
kid that was fat
i had him but if that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
diesel i was like
he ain't gonna pin me but you're gonna
run my face all over this guy damn matt
and i'm gonna get head burned all over
too yeah there's a lot of stories about
wrestling and cutting weight and i hope
they don't i don't know if they do that
anymore but we
people were taking x-lacs and all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] like that
um i never did that myself but um
um i don't know i ran off the mat one
day just
[ __ ] in my pants you know right after
the match was over i just ran
it's the it's so it probably stunts our
growth to an extent like cutting weight
and all that [ __ ] that we would do at
that age
yeah they clearly stunted um yeah
i can't believe you're 122. dude yeah
i'm like 175 now
i'm 5 10. my brothers are both over six
feet and i wonder if
part of that was was wrestling wait
you're twin brother
yeah he's six two no kidding yeah i
guess you could
but you didn't you said you didn't cut
weight so no i
i said i never was able to not cut
weight i always was cutting
did you ever have that guy who had to
gain weight to be a heavyweight
yeah we did he was eating bananas and
drinking milk right because the
only one time i ever got to do this was
the best to ever i didn't have to
i was 155 and the coach is like i'm we
don't have
or i think it was a 65 pounder was not
he got sick or whatever
he's like i want you to bump up to 65
i'm like i can't like
if it's a fat guy i got it if it's
muscle
you know i won't get pinned but we're
losing that you know and um
i will never forget everybody's remember
how people were starving and they just
wanted to weigh in
i went up on that scale and i single it
my whole sweatpants sweat jacket i had
my headgear hanging from the side and i
was eating a cup of pudding and that
thing didn't even come up and i was like
oh
was there a minimum weight no you could
be you could be 100 pounds wrestling 165
as long as you had that spot filled
that's fine
um my whole thing was showing up to
weigh in in my skivvies and my glasses
you know with the little like thing that
attached in the back and everything just
looking like a full fish
that was my movie you know this one
still i'll never forget this these guys
that were all in high school that will
never
i don't know why this would be probably
i'll probably forget my kids names at
some point with alzheimer's and remember
this [ __ ] but we called this dude mega
dick
he's got a mega death t-shirt on and his
weight was
it was going teetering like this and
they're like take your t-shirt off and
instead of taking the t-shirt off he had
like a gold chain on and he just snapped
it off his neck and throw it on the
floor and it did it for like whatever
this
[ __ ] clown oh mega dick over here
get the [ __ ] off the scale um so look i
i want to ask you about a story because
it's a i want to talk about what
happened to beck
okay can we talk about it yeah sure we
can talk about i mean walk through it
because
i know i know it but i don't know it and
and it gets [ __ ] crazy and intense so
beck is is your son he's my youngest son
he's 17.
um he had a a really good amateur
surfing career he's um
he was moving into the sort of pro ranks
until covet hit
and there's just no professional surfing
anymore right now so he's um
he's he's teaching surfing up in malibu
which is really cool
um for the time being um
and uh i guess when he was uh
i think he was uh 12 years old uh
yeah maybe a little younger
11. we went down to baja with another
couple families
um northern baja like we got a whole
house at las caviotas i don't know if
you've ever been down there but not
there
um yeah it was cool we had some good
surfing days
and uh and then the older kids wanted to
go to the atv
place which was about two miles um
south and uh and ran
atvs and then the two younger boys beck
and
his friend willie were like dad you know
we really want to go blah blah blah blah
blah and they
just chewing my ear off about it you
know and my son is super stubborn
which does make him a really good
competitor at times
and and so i was just like [ __ ] it okay
go you know so he
but you don't go with no i went with him
oh you did um
and i brought the camera so everyone's
got their atvs and off they go and i
start filming how many people total
oh probably six kids okay yeah and
you're the only adult
uh i'm the only adult there the other
dad stayed
okay i believe he stayed back yeah if
i'm not mistaken
but he was a huge help i just can't
remember if he was
at the atv so i'm filming the kids and
they're all having a good time and then
i see my older son west
coming right at me like flying and i'm
like oh cool he's going to do a little
donut or something blah blah blah
and then i see just terror on his face
and he's just like dad
beck went over a cliff back went over a
cliff
full speed like 20-foot cliff and i'm
like holy [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] up he's [ __ ] up and i'm
gonna i know i'm gonna start crying now
so
because i'm reliving it but uh
so all of a sudden i see beck
screaming up on his atv there's no
seat you know things are flapping around
and he's just bawling but coming full
speed
balling spit flying out of his mouth
crying at the top of his lungs and i'm
like all right at least he's [ __ ]
alive
so i run over there and i'm like what's
up what's up he's like my leg my leg
so i go over to the other side of the
atv and i look down
and i just see his bone you know
his his from his knee to his foot
is just splayed open like butterflied
just butterflied open all down the shin
yeah just just if this is this his yeah
it would just be from here to here god
and it just and i see the bone
and you know and i'm like oh he's just
gushing so i pick him up
i put him in the back of my truck
and um and at that point i'm just sort
of letting
other people do the ambulance stuff and
all that the guy who owns the place
called the ambulance is on his way um
and i'm
just trying to talk to my son like this
just going
he's just he's like hey am i am i going
to lose my leg bubble
you know this kid was yeah he had the
trajectory he was you know sponsored by
hurley and ton other people and
and you know i'm sure that was going
through his head and and um
and i said you're not gonna lose your
leg you're gonna be okay and then i just
fainted
you know you did i look back at my older
son and i said i'll be back in a minute
and you dropped that
i'll be back in a minute yeah yeah and i
just hit the next scary
uh just about 30 seconds maybe yeah it
was a while yeah
30 seconds is a long time and then the
panic situation but i remember like
going i'm back
you know hey you rolling over half a
minute
back quicker enough ah man i didn't know
you faded
so uh yeah
not the first time i faded i got another
good painting
um but uh um yeah so uh
then i remember the other dad showing up
because they must have called them in
and uh we got the ambulance on the way
um so i said back just i put a i think i
wrapped my belt around his thigh or
something like that
did something um and uh
then the ambulance came and we took him
to rosarito hospital
just to clean up in there i've been in
the room clean it up yeah
you've seen the cats walking around
there right so
and i gotta say i walk in there's a dude
eating a sandwich
okay at the hospital yeah and i'm like
where's the doctor and he puts a
sandwich down and he goes on the toilet
and i'm like no seriously
so uh was he really yeah he was the
doctor
but let me say something because the guy
did a tremendous job he cleaned out my
son's wound
he wrapped it real good and then he
called the other aunt all right so wait
that's what i want to go back to so the
ambulance that picks up you guys is this
like is it state-of-the-art like what
are we talking about well
yeah the ambulance certainly is state of
the art and
but so are they cleaning them out and
like are they prepping them in the
ambulance no
they're just no we just they just ran
they're not doing any okay that's why i
was wondering if there was
equipment in there where they could
start helping they was making sure that
he was conscious and everything okay and
he was
you know um but yeah then they cleaned
out the wound real good and wrapped it
up i think we were there for
maybe an hour maybe an hour and a half i
paid the ambulance i paid the hospital
cash cash
then another ambulance came that could
take us to the border
where an america u.s ambulance would
come and pick us up
so why was that well they wouldn't do
surgery there or
well i didn't want them to oh okay yeah
i just needed to get them to this states
you know
so we're in the ambulance and the guy
gets in the wrong [ __ ] lane to the
border yeah so 45 minutes people are
trying to sell me churros and [ __ ] bro
and my son's bleeding out in the back
man
every now and then i'm like you okay
like you want a churro he's like nah i'm
good
and you got my last supper
classic monkey plastic monkey surfing
monkey
you need a blanket i've been through
that border check
so i'm [ __ ] just bought a last supper
plaque flipping out
and at that point so they can't turn
their lights on and and get people
we thought we were going in the fast
lane but what they've done is they've
sold that fast
lane now to fastpass people
so you're just in line with everybody
else but he got an actual wrong line not
even in the fastpass right
so at that point i called my wife who's
in la and i'm like look you got to meet
us down here in san diego just get in
your car and she's like what happened i
said there's been an
accident it wasn't surfing just come you
know
and i called the hospital just over the
border
i don't want to say the name of it but
the lady at the front desk was so
[ __ ] cool and she goes uh
you don't want to come here she goes go
to radie's children's hospital which is
another 10 minutes just take him there
and i was like okay so when we got there
um oh first of all [ __ ] we got to the
border
and then we transfer in the ambulance
and i'm like let's go let's go and
they're like no
we gotta unwrap and see if you got drugs
in this wound and i was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me i you know i
the guy these kids got to get sewn up
it's bad i said it's really bad and
they're like how bad am i
really bad so they're like we still have
to do it it's protocol so they
unwrapped them and you know made sure
there wasn't drugs in the wound how
[ __ ] drastic is that
yeah but i bet they've seen everything
i'm sure they have man so they were
they were cool they wrapped it back up
we went to radies children's hospital
and we got
into the operating room right away
and uh and the nurses were so cool they
already had
beck surfing edit on an ipad
as soon as they rolled them in they're
like is this you and wow yeah
and and he goes yeah that's me and
they're like wow what tell me about that
move
meanwhile keeping them off yeah and the
doctors are like
you got one second if you want to take a
snap of this wound before we heal it up
so i walked in there and went snap and
uh that's the picture i sent you yeah
that thing is
gnarly let's take a quick break and tell
you about our first sponsor oh max
cryofreeze
living with chronic pain is the worst
it's more than a feeling of discomfort
it can affect your whole life
many of you probably have some type of
pain that's prevented you from relaxing
and sleeping or stopped you from
exercising
perhaps it's been ongoing for a few
weeks now and hasn't improved with any
of the treatments you've tried
enter oh max health if you're looking to
get rid of nagging muscle and joint pain
immediately while providing long lasting
recovery
then you need to try the natural
breakthrough pain relief solution
cryo-free cbd roll-on developed by omax
health this non-prescription triple
action
pain relief roll-on is specially
formulated to block pain receptors
reduce inflammation
and improve muscle and joint flexibility
and the best part is
this 100 natural cbd powered remedy
works its magic within 10 minutes of
application
and relief lasts up to 8 hours which is
much longer
than the over-the-counter products i've
been telling you guys for months now
about the shoulder pain i had if you
really watch these podcasts hard you
don't have to
um i couldn't lean on my elbow i would
get numbness shooting all through my
elbow i had to i would keep getting
uncomfortable with it
and i'm telling you that omax carol
freeze worked omax health is offering
my listeners you ready 20 off a full
body cryo-free cbd pain relief on plus
free shipping this discount also applies
toward any product
site-wide so just go to omaxhealth.com
today enter code honeydew that's
omax health.com
and enter code honeydew to get 20 off
cryofreeze
and site wide let's tell you about our
next sponsor hellofresh
get fresh pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door with
hellofresh america's number one
meal kit hellofresh lets you skip those
trips to the grocery store
and makes home cooking fun easy and
affordable
hellofresh's recipes are so delicious
they offer so many recipes to choose
from each week to help you break out of
your recipe rut
and there's something for everyone
they've got low calorie they got
vegetarian they have these family
friendly recipes
every week which is aka picky eaters
hellofresh offers fresh high quality
ingredients every week for a
super flavorful experience over ninety
percent of the ingredients are sourced
directly from growers to ensure the
freshest
recipes are delivered to your door save
time and stress
effortlessly hello fresh offers
contactless delivery to your doorstep
for easy home cooking with the family
hello fresh cuts out stressful meal
planning
and grocery store trips so you can enjoy
cooking and get dinner on the table in
just 30 minutes or even 20 minutes with
their quick recipe options
here's what you gotta do go to
hellofresh.com
honeydew80 all right and use code
honeydew80
to get a total of eighty dollars off
including free shipping on your first
box all right additional restrictions do
apply
please visit hellofresh.com for details
that's hellofresh.com
slash honeydew80. now let's get back to
the do
yeah i thought i ruined my son's life
you know yeah making that decision
worst decision i ever made in my life
but like which one you mean
letting him go letting him go you know
like and i saw the atv was too big for
him you know
and so was the helmet and you know it's
just like [ __ ] man
yeah all that parent gut stuff and then
you know there's a
there's a that should have been marked
with tires you know this cliff
and it wasn't and everything's dunes
so you just think i'll just go over this
dune and he gunned it and [ __ ]
boom just free fell so what happened
was anything broken was it a he broke
his back
his back that one you didn't even know
that at that point right
yeah that after we got to the hospital
they did an mri i didn't
i don't remember that so he broke a
vertebrae a couple of vertebrae in his
back
and then he had uh how many stitches
dude i don't know
six yeah it was the stitches or staples
that closed that leg up there was
stitches and then staples
damn yeah and i thought like literally i
like uh they said um you know we may
have to do like all this graph and all
this stuff
if it's not taking and so my wife and i
were agonizing you know in the waiting
room like
[ __ ] i just [ __ ] my kid's life up you
know and uh
and uh so he uh the the doctor came out
and said we were we were able to
you know do it without any graphs or
anything you know blah blah blah
so then it was a big tough recovery time
for him that was a hard time for him
being in a wheelchair and all that yeah
because he can't
do anything he's active as well it took
him five months to get back in the water
i think
damn and how's it now he's good now he's
got a huge scar
yeah i'm sure he lost some strength out
of that calf you know
what took longer to heal the leg or his
back i feel like your back was
i think the leg took longer to heal yeah
yeah
just just in a sense that you don't want
to get infected
with going back in the water he'd get a
[ __ ] ton of rehab
thank you sophia costa by the way who's
pt
um i didn't know you passed out yeah man
you said you had another one you passed
oh yeah well
that was the first time i ever got a bj
no
yeah for sure i it wasn't at the time it
was after
okay so it was the first time
yeah i guess i could say who it was so
when we came out i'll say i'm not gonna
say who was when we came back from miami
my mom you know my mom had this way of
you know meeting guys and
moving into their house with us so we
moved into this dude's house in coconut
grove and
he had a really cool family um but yeah
um
one of uh one of the daughters you know
hooked up with her and uh i just
remember like i was like wow this is
amazing you know getting that first time
like i was thinking i was 15
you know 16. and then i got up to piss
and in the middle of my piss i hit the
porcelain so [ __ ] hard dude
i just went boom bounced off
how long were you out for that one it's
never happened again man so that must
have been the best [ __ ] in my life
it's all downhill from now
passed out yeah man did she know it did
she come in i don't think she knew
what's that bump on your lip like what
you should have [ __ ] she probably
would have been like oh my god she knows
now
i guess so anyway
man you and i got fired together how
about that we got fired twice together
yeah the same day same day yeah yeah
uh well it we won't say where but we
were working together
and rhymes with disney on a project yeah
on a project that i remember
you got called first yeah we were
editing ahead of bay
and i was like all right i'll save you
some pizza uh-huh and then i got
i was like let me take this pizza oh man
i remember lighting a cigar and being
escorted off the lot
yeah i they were like do you need a box
for your things i'm like no i don't keep
anything here i i'm just gonna grab my
bag
our office is right right next door yeah
you introduced me to
uh the ricky gervais office in that
building oh yeah here's another thing in
that building too and i i've never tried
this ever again but do you remember that
time
we were sitting at the commissary like
outside it was
almost end of the day and you had some
cigars yeah but you're like my brother
sent these up with some rum
oh yeah but they broke and uh the cigars
got rum
soaked but now they're dried out and we
had to go back we had like an hour or
two of work left and i smoked maybe
a quarter of that cigar and let me tell
you i was [ __ ]
really i was [ __ ] up more than i've
ever been
like on weed or anything i was like god
you can
there you have it kids soak your cigars
in a room cuban cigars
accidentally soaked in rum and we smoked
them and it [ __ ] me up i thought it
was tequila
thinking back on it because i remember
he said yeah whatever
it [ __ ] me up yeah that was the cigar
i lit on my way out the door
right there that was a crazy place too
man that whole
prospect lot that's where we were on the
prospect lot in los feliz
yeah man well
now look now look man here we are now
you know i'm i'm super thankful that i
have a job you know and i'm i'm
i'm really thankful that you know you
get to continue doing this thing i hope
it's making you some money
you know because i know you're not on
the road anymore not at all you know
nobody is yeah i like i i turn on the
facebook every now and then and and you
know some of the comedians are just so
it just seems like desperate times right
now and i i feel bad for
a lot of my friends out there you know
um
but listen hey uh hopefully things will
turn around and people can
get back on stage and you know look man
i haven't panicked it's all good
it's gonna be whatever the [ __ ] it is
when comedy does come back it'll be
it'll be awesome when it does come back
but it's not gonna be
i mean joey diaz just hit me up it's 20
21 and philly is canceled the shows are
cancelled till i mean excuse me 2020
till
2021 february i think it is new year's
parade
already gone like it's until there's
probably a vaccine you're not gonna see
the comedy store
packed out like it was and you know all
these venues packed at concerts arenas
you know football stadiums all that [ __ ]
but uh i want to talk about you got some
more stories here i don't know what
first time
second time is first time second time oh
the second time i got laid
i think i told this story on uh your
other podcast
yeah on the crab feast and um but yeah
the second time i laid the
the the girl who i
slept with the first time was the same
blow job girl okay
and then she must have reacted you lost
your virginity to the girl that made you
pass
i would too after that and um it was
amazing
and she read i guess she recommended me
to one of her friends or something
so she came over but she had a full
like back brace on that was screwed into
her temple
the halo dude yeah so but she was super
cute
my friend rebecca had one of those
because she broke her neck
yeah so i guess she was just ready to
get laid after a lot of rehab or
something but it was still on
it was still on but i took it we i
helped her take it off her robocop
i helped her take it off i remember and
i had to be super gentle yeah with her
but it was you know that's how you know
how horny you are when you're a kid
because as a girl and a doll you're like
let's just wait for that i'll say oh
yeah
i'll work around that that seems fine
just give me a three seconds
must have been so horny too to take that
whole thing off it's dangerous to take
that off let's hand me an allen wrench
let's get to it
oh man yeah yeah that was kind of nuts
man i don't know
[ __ ] happens to me you know that was a
weird one dude but
but that was an introduction to sex like
the first two times one faint one
thing i didn't know what was coming i
mean you must be into some freaky
[ __ ] [ __ ] now to get all fainted and
robocop
i don't you know i'm so i've been
married 21 years you know to my lovely
wife emma and
thank you um oh dude she's a she's in
your business
always up my ass always everything's
always a
an insult with a smile oh yeah that's my
whole life
yeah but um we you know we we don't i i
think the first um
i remember the first our first date we
were talking about anal sex
okay like i've never i've never done it
i've never
had it i've never done it to me or do
somebody
and i think we were chatting about it
and i'm like oh i like this girl she's
talking about anal sex but i but her
proposition to me was i will if you will
in other words
if you go buy a [ __ ] dildo and i can
peg you
shove it up your ass you can do that to
me and so i just never took her up on it
it's been 21 years
old yeah she did a good thing she was
like here's the deal
but it's just never interested me like
weird kinky sex had never
never interested me at all i don't know
i'm just not down with that
what's the when it comes to dating like
what's the weirdest
date or breakup or anything like that
you've ever had
it was probably it was probably the it
was probably the head trauma
i'm not sure i can beat that dude i mean
i'm like what's on my knee she's like
that's one of my bolts you know
[Laughter]
dude i'll never forget walking in and
like and i had to make that decision
like
you know am i going to get laid or do i
have to deal with this [ __ ] and
it wasn't even she was cute though super
cute
but she wanted to have sex with that
thing on she wanted to have it with it
off
which really scared you you know but um
yeah and then you had to help her put it
back on and she had the little divots
you know
rebecca's still got the scars where it
bolts into your skull yeah
it is nuts dude you put it back on it
put it back on
everything most dudes won't [ __ ] wear
a condom no i just left her writhing on
the bathroom floor
look what i got you put it on my head
like
robocop
[Music]
oh my god man yeah i wonder
that's crazy but i did get a i got a
phone call you know like uh i got the
apology phone call like 20 years later
from
from you know one of my one of the women
i had sex with you know that was a
little weird
what do you mean you know that that the
alcoholics anonymous
i just talked about that on an episode
i've gotten them from
yeah i've gotten them from aaa i've
gotten them from
sex addiction i've gotten them from food
addiction
got them from coke addiction well you
never even done below how are you
involved in that they
are emailing me and saying hey i had a
problem when i was with you i'm sorry i
treated you like [ __ ] like it's the
apology email
wow and that was what they were doing
and email's okay i got the phone call
i got it i got text i got text i got
text not email but i got text
yeah that was a crazy phone call but you
know i was like it's cool
that's what i said i was like yeah well
i knew i mean yeah you did cocaine in
front of me yes
i tried to tell you that's wrong
yeah growing up in miami in the eight
and uh yeah you know 79 80 81
so much cocaine you know and my my one
of my best friends all
i had three three really good friends
and they were all second generation
cubans
their parents came over in 59 and they
were born in 63
same time i was and they were just my
boys growing up
and uh and one of them's dad ran
the cuban mafia from the dade county
jail they had him in there on tax
evasion
but he was still running the show man
and and uh
and i we would go to this guy's house on
a friday night
after school and his mom would make us a
big steak
in a cuban pan and it was so delicious
and then we'd go in the back where his
brothers were and the oozies
and the giant pile of cocaine on the
table you wouldn't see this we would get
a ziploc bag with our hand and just go
like that and how old are you
16 17 18 yeah that's how it was down
there man that was nuts
and so uh yeah we'd go out for the night
would you sell it or is that just for no
that was just for us to go go [ __ ]
around with
[ __ ] yeah yeah man that was crazy times
man [ __ ]
you know square grouper would would
float up on shore you know in my high
school
um in key biscayne it would be you know
the cigarette boats were running all the
drugs and then when they got busted
they'd toss them over
and so every now and then you know jimmy
jimmy would find a square grouper and it
would go around the school what is that
that that's what we call the bale of
wheat you know that weed
yes but the the albino grouper
was the cocaine and so uh
i've seen cocaine cowboys where they
were literally just dropping on the
beaches and
you could go [ __ ] grab it yeah that
was a it was it was weird like that
and there were so many murders like when
i was growing up you know like people
were just getting
capped left and right in miami just drug
drug deals gone bad
and all cocaine was just what i grew up
with and in fact
it's a big influence in my comic book
you know um
the main character kony shiki he has a a
a drug problem in real life can i tell a
little bit about the comic book of
course
all right so basically what this what
this world is
is um these superheroes you don't have
to do all that
they toggle between um
they're game avatars these guys are the
most popular
game avatars in the world and they're
you know and uh
but when the game turns off you know
where the [ __ ] do they go and so
um that's when uh you know
the story came out that oh well they
just go to a four-bedroom house in san
fernando valley and try and live their
life like normal people
but every now and then they get have to
get they get zapped back into their game
because they're players right
whenever that's right yeah and and some
people sort of go oh that doesn't make
any sense
but i kind of just i explain it like
this if you have a dog
and a doggy door okay in our world in
our vocabulary
there's inside and there's outside but
that dog doesn't
put that together they just know as soon
as they slam through that door
it's like a miracle you know like
something else this is [ __ ] out here
so that's kind of how i describe it you
know and these guys are toggling back
and forth and there's
there's a villain who who shows his face
and he's gonna be a
through line through the whole piece and
um so uh
you know i hope people like it uh i hope
uh it
it resonates with some of the gaming
crowd and some of the superhero crowd
um you know i'm a huge fan of like doom
patrol
and the boys and all that stuff and this
is kind of in that same genre so if you
like that kind of cool [ __ ]
check out the comic book there you go
did you tell i've been in tv for a while
um
i want to hear this james beach story oh
james beach so james beach
to gray bar or what was a great bar it's
still
open but not now of course but um
my boy um john henry binder who now owns
venice duck brewery so
you know okay i had the i had that beer
at james beach yeah yeah
it was his right yeah and you probably
was served by him yes
and um so he was there for 25 years
and he was gonna wrap it up because he
started this brewery company
and it was like gonna be his last week
and i have partied in james beach
a lot of times and gotten a little nuts
in there
um and uh so i'm like all right i'm
gonna go back
i'm gonna go early i'm gonna you know
have a few drinks with john henry before
it gets all nuts on a wednesday not a
saturday is last night on a wednesday
so i walk in it's pretty much empty and
i take my normal seed on the corner
there
and uh i start drinking you know and and
having a good time and
we're shooting this [ __ ] this dude pulls
up next to me
and uh he goes uh you want to do a line
and i'm like and he holds up the little
baggie and then like about 10 minutes
later dude
this guy leans over just like this in my
ear
i just want to do a line of blow off
your [ __ ]
like right in my ear
and i was like check please john henry
give me the check
so he gives me the check and i whisper
in john henry's ear i'm like these are
the last words i heard at your bar
and i told it to him and he fell out and
i walked out the door that's the last
time i've been there
[Laughter]
[ __ ] james beach man i used to have
all my parties
big christmas parties at uh the canal
club and james beach you know when i
owned four-eyed films weren't they
across from each other owned by the same
people oh they were okay
yeah yeah yeah that was nuts man but
that place
you know you're there early
and then you just see it turn ugly bro
and the lion faces come in
and it just it gets nuts dude
that's the truth like a lion oh my
goodness
all right so you and i have known each
other for a long time a long time and
you've been around my wife
a lot always insults me with a smile a
british
it's a real british [ __ ] you i feel like
your wife is a brit
and it's always like ryan you know it's
always this pleasant hello and
and then there's a co a compliment that
comes for you look like you've lost
weight
your face looks like [ __ ] though you
know it's always some follow-up like
damn
every [ __ ] time but i love it and she
loves doing it
obviously it's usually about your
singledom or something like that
you know or whatever situation you're
currently in
somehow she knows about it always yeah
always has good advice
always offers me a a meal yeah always
she's a good brother time i went to the
laundry room
to get a shirt out of a basket okay
and um i look i've been around laundry
my whole life
okay so i put the shirt on and it
smelled to me it smelled a little
unfresh
and sometimes you get those ones in the
laundry you know what i'm saying they're
like
how was that one balled up or something
yeah yeah it got stuck in my fitted
sheet that's right
sweetheart come here smell this it
smells on fresh to me and you know what
she said
you just don't know what fresh smells
like that's that's a white [ __ ] thing
to say that's what you said
and that stuck with me so i don't ask do
you remember that line you don't know a
fresh smell yeah you don't know what
fresh smells like that's what she's
telling what is it
what is it to you she said it smells
great it's fine
anyway but um recently
get on this is this is kind of an
embarrassing story but i'm going to tell
it anyway
please it was about 10 o'clock there's
another uh
my life story it was about 10 o'clock at
night so i went outside for a night cap
you know and uh this is i don't think
i've ever told anyone this [ __ ] story
so um uh um so
um smoking a joint and i got a piss
so i piss in my spot in my backyard you
know men
have a spot you can see the browns
yeah yeah you can see it so um i'm
pissing smoking a joint
and the cherry of the joint falls
and hits the tip of my dick
tip to tip okay swear to god
so i smacked my dick so hard bam
and blood starts coming out the tip of
my dick and
i have a burn wait so wait i think i
burst a blood
of also when i smell okay all right
okay so this is kissing blood now
just a couple little drops because i
smacked the [ __ ] i think i
like this has never happened to me maybe
maybe when i had a catheter
or something like i can't even i had it
happened but
so i'm freaking out and it's like a
thursday night and my wife and i
have sex every sunday okay that's just
the thing we do
we get together on sunday and you know
work about 15 minutes in
and we go our separate ways like eagles
in the night you know
so so i
i kind of wait a couple days the blood
thing stops immediately so i'm like okay
thank god that's
that's gone but there is a little mark
you know and i like i've only been with
my wife for
this entire time you've been married so
um it's saturday it's still there
and sunday and you have you so you
didn't even tell her that happened i
know
but then before like i go okay look i'm
gonna tell you something because
if you got a sore on your dick and you
and you've been married for 20.
okay good luck bro
i just been packing my [ __ ] up like i'm
telling you the truth but i'm gonna stay
at a hotel tonight
okay so i just i told her the truth i
figured the truth
okay so i said look i'm outside i'm
taking a piss
i'm smoking a joint the [ __ ] cherry
fell and hit me in the dick and i have a
little burn
you know what she said to me you don't
know what fresh smells like
she goes i can't believe you were
[ __ ] taking a piss in the backyard
that's a good wife that's a good boy
didn't even [ __ ] care
she didn't blink about that other part
but she was pissed about the piss
but she wanted to see it then um it was
gnarly huh how long did it take to heal
a couple weeks that's a that's a
sensitive [ __ ] spot it wouldn't
be anything i mean you know how when you
get a spider on you or whatever yeah
like that's how that's how i react bruce
lee yeah
um damn stole my punch line but it's
okay it's your show
that's all right it's your show it's
your show it's fine
uh anyway um god damn dude
[Applause]
that's some [ __ ] you would say to me
though i was ready for it that's funny
though
um anyway so um
have we uh i wanted to ask you you told
me a story
well you told me something about your
dad and camp
yeah oh man i don't know what it was
maybe it was like
it the time in this in the 70s you know
like
yeah because you're a little i'm 47 how
old are you i'm 10 years older so you're
50. damn are you really 57 i am you look
[ __ ]
great dude you're almost 60 bro i know
right i'm on the
wrong side of 55 as they say [ __ ] you're
alive you're on the right side of 55
the wrong side is dead people talking
about it but listen it takes a lot of
work yeah it looks good i got good jeans
you surf you do i do have good genes
though my dad's 90.
you know yeah he's still that's a big
amazing you know like
he's there's there's nothing lost there
you know he's
he's on point he can't hear as well but
he's he's definitely on on
super sharp you know um and always has
been but
when i was eight all right um
he drove me to sleep away camp
four weeks bro four [ __ ] weeks
by yourself no i mean let me say say
this
it's an eight-week camp okay my brother
was there
already he's been there for a couple of
years since he was eight
but um uh so he was there already the
first four weeks and he my dad was
driving me up for the second four weeks
at how far away from home is this so we
lived in miami
okay and um so the nice jewish camp was
called camp coleman and it's in florida
and we drove past that camp
and i waved to all my friends
so he drove me to um camp chatuga
in north carolina which is where they
shot deliverance
is that right i am not kidding on the
chatuga river
is where they shot deliverance and so um
now they know that i always thought it
was in west virginia for some reason the
camp
was awesome the campbell was i i was
eight years old
so it was it was a draw it was a couple
days four hours no
dude there's a couple days i think we
stopped in orlando and spent the night
and then we drove the rest of the way so
here's what i'm getting at is
you're taking your kids and you're just
leaving them
there's there's no cell phones or texts
oh no there's none of that
you don't even talk to him for a few
weeks that's what i'm saying it's just
letters back and yeah and it's not like
a commute where he can ride up
an hour and go see you no i think
there's parent day but i don't
know if my parents came you know
a long drive right that's what i'm
saying um
and there were some kids who got the
care packages you know
like uh spaghettios and sterno and they
could we could make spaghettios in the
[ __ ]
cabin and [ __ ] like that uh my friend
eddie friedman always got the good care
packages but
um uh didn't get the care packages but
here's
here's my little um highlighting the low
light story about
camp and that first day we got there
in the morning he dropped me off we said
goodbye
and and you're how old again eight eight
and we went
on a ten mile hike to dairy queen okay
five miles there eight year old five
miles there and five miles back
how many kids would you say fifteen and
how many counselors two
[Music]
and i should i said girls
at mile three bro on the way there
[ __ ] yourself so bad like just
like you know and and i would say
probably for a mile and a half i was
trying my hardest
you know that moment where you just
can't
so what do you do so i went into the
bathroom when we got the dairy queen
and uh you walked two more miles yeah
hold on i have a million yes is it
diarrhea
is it like running down your legs yes
there's a little bit
running down my leg and and have you
notified anybody i have
not i am embarrassed are you in the back
of the line
58 now i was eight
and i just driven two days with my dad
and got dropped off in a state i've
never
you know like i just learned about in
geography like
you know so um i get i get into the
bathroom a dairy queen i take my
underwear off and i throw it in the
you know in the trash can i try and
clean myself up best i can
and then i never got any ice cream
because by the time i was done
there it was time all right finish your
closure
oh my god damn probably shouldn't have
been eating ice cream anyway
[Laughter]
so um uh we got back and uh
it was the beginning of the week of
course because it was that first week
that first
day of for the four weeks and i put all
my clothes in my
in the hamper and everyone had their
hampers hanging up at the end of the
beds
but the laundry had just been done you
know so my shitty clothes
like i was the shitty kid no i was the
shitty kid i was like oh there's a
shitty kid
you know they would say you'd hear
people say that
it's brutal but the shitty kid
you know once the laundry got out that
first after the end of the week
um you know
eventually i you know i wasn't a shitty
kid anymore and i did go to that camp
like four years because
yeah because the longer you went the
cooler [ __ ] you got to do you got to go
to six flags
you got to go down the chatuca river and
camp you know and i lost my glasses on
that trip and the chitoga river and the
deliverance river
in the deliverance room yeah yeah anyway
so yeah that's my [ __ ] camp story but
did you ever go to camp i only went i
was gonna tell you i went to a soccer
camp
um at bucknell university in
pennsylvania
um it was my brother my twin brother
myself my younger brother was too young
at the time and then another friend of
ours
greg carr fine it was uh we all played
soccer with so the three of us went to
this camp and we stayed in the dorms at
the college and there were older kids
there and [ __ ]
how old were you this was middle school
probably
so 11 12 years in that area okay um
right before high school and
i was on the red team my brother was on
the uh i think the green
team and greg was on the blue team and
we had all played together
the whole time so we really loved
playing against each other you know so
we really talk [ __ ] like yeah [ __ ] you
now you know what i mean and my team won
the whole championship
but i do remember being embarrassed and
clown because back in the day
i wore my socks all the way up you know
i mean the three striped socks i pulled
them up to
just under my knees there's still some
skin between your socks and this
yeah yeah yeah there was back then there
was yeah there was
a little just a knee it was like well
because the shorts were shorter yeah
that's it
they weren't you know i'm wearing
umbrellas and [ __ ] have the little
before they made the longer little v
up the side little slit and um
i remember the older kids who had
started pushing their socks down
were like oh wait nice socks and i was
like
you were the soccer kid you were the
shitty guy
yeah i would have traded that monica any
day bro
but i just remember and it was that day
that i started pushing my socks
like if you just saw me an hour later my
socks were
down you know what i mean i don't know
why that's so weird
it's i don't know why we allow people to
affect us like i remember that's such
dumb [ __ ] just the dumbest [ __ ] ever
your socks are high
but some people go through life and they
don't allow that they don't give a [ __ ]
like shawn wright you know that kid with
the red hair does
the kid has the worst [ __ ] style and
clothes but he put out a clothing line
you know and everyone bought it i think
um well everyone knocks adam sandler for
the way he dresses they do wear red
sweatpants to the oscars but right so
what
in a hockey jersey so yeah who gives a
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] look at him look
what he's doing
yeah you don't like him for his fashion
i don't look to adam saying that's like
fashion sense yeah
yeah he's funny he's comfortable with
that and he's just funny he delivers all
these he's already making me laugh
yes that's it that's it yeah this guy
we're honking jerseys
that's right that's exactly right
oh man so um
[Music]
uh i do want to say one thing about
you know i talked about that back story
a little bit and it just hit me
um you should probably have him on a
tell that story or at least on pantheon
or whatever
patreon patreon i should start something
called pantheon is that what they say
so many people why is that what is that
word i have no idea
i'm not intelligent enough to know what
pantheon yeah i don't either i'm sorry
hey
kids right in and left some greek [ __ ] i
don't know why it's some greeks oh
yeah maybe um what was i talking about
yeah so that we have him on the on the
patreon
and tell that story but um i remember
you know there was a couple things that
um like my other son west he's older and
you know he's the one who's like dad you
know my [ __ ] back
i just remember him being super cool the
whole time
and i left him in mexico you know
yeah how old was he
probably 6 15 or 16. wow yeah i left him
and his friends in mexico you know
yeah he does have a very zen to me he's
got that phil jackson demeanor yeah he
was
yeah he was cool as a cucumber and and
thank god because yeah and beck was too
i mean he was conscious the whole time
and just being super cool i mean i was
the one flipping the [ __ ] out you know
well here he is worrying about losing
his leg
and i know you're worried about him
dying like yeah
i don't think he got a look at it
actually until
or i don't know if he ever did i don't
know if he ever looked down and
looked at it you know i'm not sure you
have to ask him i don't know man but
that
that was some crazy fun that is crazy
[ __ ] but i appreciate you letting me
come in here and
talking [ __ ] listen first of all you
know i love you we go back
to late 1900s i say all the time
and a few shitty jobs
together oh man always laughing always
having a good time with you
we've we've even fought i remember
having blowouts with you
yeah because of that dumb [ __ ]
and i don't mind [ __ ] saying it right
here
oh yeah you know what i yeah yeah so
but who hasn't i mean any good friend of
mine or family
i mean you have at least one blowout for
sure and then you find out whether
you're really friends or not after that
that's right because some people just go
their separate ways like oh we weren't
it wasn't really that thick after all so
and also you come across people in this
industry where
you know most of the time you're not
rooting for them you just aren't
you know but you're someone yeah you
know even when
we were both coming up i i just
respected your comedy and your writing
uh first of all and so i just say i'm
rooting for this guy he's a good guy
well i appreciate you dude you gave me
my first
real long stage time at the boathouse
back in the day when we would do that
well you would do the monthly show and
allow me to be on it with mark dominique
yeah we've talked about that mark
dominique jody pershing who's not
no longer here oh really yeah you
remember her i remember her yeah
she passed she passed away about five
years ago yeah um
but all this this studio was during the
whole lockdown
you came in we we hung this a little
crooked
yeah we put strikes up stripes down
but i'm the most proud of these these
things behind yeah
and you can order these posters am i
right yeah you can if you want a [ __ ]
12 by 12
of my head yeah you get that you can now
order these on
what's that [ __ ] called when you stick
those things up fat
fat head dude how would a great fat head
that thing would make huh yeah well
that's originally what i started looking
at yeah that's a fat head get in touch
with ryan let's get him on this yeah
what's up let's go let's get some
honeydew fat heads i like it
hey man thank you for everything thank
you for all your help um
please promote your your book we had it
sitting here like uh
oh yeah remember yeah yeah that time
and you didn't have as much of this and
i i had more of this
yeah um i mean you know yeah what are
you gonna do
so um yes here's the deal um
look it's not the most um socially
conscious thing to do right now as an
artist
to put out some selfish [ __ ] comic
book but
um but also i was working on this long
before this
these projects aren't something that you
flip overnight and i really wanted to
march this thing when it
when i was done with it when it came out
in march but
um you know more important things you
know have happened in the world
and so i kind of put my little
selfishness aside for a while but
[ __ ] man i did your show and now's the
time to promote it so
we're gonna do the kickstarter campaign
so just go to kickstarter
and search commando place and you'll
find the kickstarter program
and i'm not going to make any money on
the kickstarter all i'm doing is trying
to pay my artist
and get five more books done and then
start the next series that's really what
i want to do so
we have a low goal and if you can chip
in a few bucks and be part of it
um there's certain um things that you
get for different donations and stuff
like that that's how kickstarter works
so um yeah appreciate anything is it
just kickstarter.com
and then search for man no place that's
right and you'll see
the project is there a link anywhere on
a website that they could go directly to
to take them there um there is and will
you um is there
maybe you can just put that in the uh
um i do have like i think it's um
kickstarter.com
commando please send us the link and
we'll put it in the youtube description
okay that'd be great thank you so much
for course yeah and thank you all
i love your fans you know you always
tell me you know not to get involved but
i love doing the photoshop stuff i don't
know if
anyone knows but i i i sometimes i
submit
photoshop [ __ ] to you and you put it up
and uh that makes me all proud you know
i love all that stuff yeah yeah i'll
find some honeydew [ __ ] in the store and
i'm not i don't know i i think that um
i don't know i'm not like a lot of the
people i meet in this industry and that
that i just i don't feel like them i
feel like
everyone else yeah you know what i mean
i oh yeah you're always been a genuine
person i am just
a regular person i live in a [ __ ] two
bedroom
one bath apartment with no goddamn
central air or heat with
tandem [ __ ] parking with a lot of
crime in my neighborhood
and pay 2 000 a month in [ __ ] up los
angeles
but this is where my family is this is
where my kids are so this is where i am
and i am so fortunate to have
to tremendous fans fantastic people that
i
i it makes me feel so good when
other comics well but when they could go
to their shows or like man i had
a dozen people there because they heard
me on the honeydew and they were the
nicest people
if it's every comics that you have the
best fans oh my god i'm getting so much
love oh my god this feels great thank
you they're coming on here and talking
about [ __ ] and trauma
and then the love that showed to them
and i'm not always tagged in that you
know someone's like hey look at this
message someone sent me i'm like oh
that's
[ __ ] awesome so i have great fans um
i'm very fortunate for it especially
even to be in a time we're in right now
where people can't work
that anybody would even want to listen
to me i'm just always
i'll never not be flattered blown away
surprised you know the moment i'm
sucking my own dick then
it's a wrap right you know and by the
way if i could do that i would stay in
the house all the goddamn time you know
what i'm saying so
i'm fortunate to have good people um and
it's just like being a proud parent when
your kid comes back from a sleepover and
they're like
your kid was so well-mannered you're
like what a shock because you have a
[ __ ] douchebag in my house right
but you better [ __ ] do that for sure
and that's what it feels like
you got a good one the honeydew fans the
crab feast fans
the comedy fans wherever you have found
me thank you all so much and thank you
too dude look at this place yeah this is
awesome look at this [ __ ] place so
i'm so excited to be here and and ash
ash out there my producers the [ __ ]
killing it's
we're we got a great team working
together we're going to keep putting up
some content and
um you know go from there so thank you
for being a big part of it
my pleasure dude i was happy to open
ryan's house of masturbation
whenever i can rub it out i'm telling
you i knew exactly what you were doing
as soon as you showed me this space i
was like
all right man thank you so much yeah so
wait one more time
go to uh kickstarter search commando
please that's right and you can um
and we'll have a link in the youtube
description yeah and
and on instagram commando place has a
little uh instagram account
where you can see a lot of the artwork
there and you can add to my 400
followers if you want on my personal
instagram
i don't care if you do or don't frankly
it would be awesome if you followed me i
do put my artwork up there so
um thank you guys again and thank you
ryan of course man thank you brother
uh as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you